hey theo my name is aaron hightower
and hey aaron and thank you for calling
i like aaron man it's a name a mixed
name
could be male or female pet anything bro
mystery ghost even gang brother praise
god
i've been a video game programmer for a
couple of years worked with a lot of
folks
and i wanted to get your take on what's
called the simulation hypothesis
i think there was a story that went
around december 30th or so
uh hit fox news and it's been doing the
circuits i haven't seen everywhere it's
been but
um yeah there's a guy
michio kaku kaku
uh and he's got some comments on it but
yeah i wanted to get your take i thought
you would
give us an entertaining insight from
your perspective what it might all be
about thanks for everything you're doing
theo
huge fan take care thank you very much
aaron
assimilation hypothesis by kakach
all right this says do we live in
assimilation
gauging whether or not we dwell inside
someone else's computer may come down to
advanced ai research
or measurements at the frontiers of
cosmology
you know do we live in assimilation do
we live in a computer
man it really a lot of it really starts
to
feel like it you know and i think for me
some of it is because of how much time i
spend on a computer
or next to electronics
you know it's gonna feel like it
it's gonna feel
i'm gonna feel like i'm locked into a
database of course i'm gonna feel like
i'm
probably being controlled by one i'm a
computer sends me an email it tells me
that email usually a lot of times tell
me what i need to do next where am i
going
i put it into a calendar so i go check
on a calendar
and the calendar tells me okay this we
have to be tomorrow two
three seven pm hear who hears who else
is coming
so it starts to be really that i'm
following
and storing things that are important to
me in an electronic world
so much so that
that i could easily see why if enough
people suggested
that we were living in assimilation
it wouldn't be hard for me to maybe feel
that way
that somebody was you know nintendo
switching me
especially a lot of people switching sex
as they get older
like somebody just you know
you know did l2 smash the right
uh l2 and then smash the r and then damn
you know
larry's got a [ __ ] now
you know or bridgette wants some tits
now
and that's that could be something
that's happening
um
do i feel like it
i think if i start to give to that idea
then that's not going to be good for me
i wonder how i would feel say if i cut
off all electronics for myself for six
months would i still feel like i'm in
assimilation
or would i just start to notice that a
lot of people are addicted to
electronics and electronica and digi and
digitalia
um
is also i don't understand sometimes if
we are say we're an assimilation
sometimes you know i remember sometimes
i would just leave the game on
i'd be playing playstation playstation
[Music]
or something i would just leave the game
on i would go
that's what i worry about sometimes that
somebody started assimilation and then
maybe they got attacked or maybe they
went outside to get something and
somebody cut them
you know you know or really disemboweled
them
and they're never coming back to the
machine
so it's kind of like in like war of uh
what is that thing called sim
not sims but um
bat it's like a battle thing where you
have crops and you know
hey donny get the wood you know hey
cheryl huh
won't you farm farm
so let you know it has that whole thing
going on and i wonder if sometimes that
is just
on that screen where they went outside
to get the mail somebody popped them off
and now they're never coming back to the
controls again
so now we're just stuck here on this one
page where nothing
ever kind of happens and we're starting
to lose our minds a little
but also i think we're just
one little ice age or not even an ice
age just like a real
you know kind of a it's gonna be chilly
out there today
age and
away from us having to get back to
ourselves and what
and what it feels like to just be
to connect with a different source we
spend so much time connecting to this to
this source
that of course we start to feel like
part of it
you know if i have seven pickles i'm
gonna feel like a list of like you know
i'm gonna feel a little green baby you
feel me
and i'm gonna start believing in green
[ __ ]
so i think that's where i am with it i
never felt that the rest of my life
so it's interesting that suddenly now
within the past five years when we were
getting
so i mean my device is always with me
it's never more than 10 minutes before i
respond to a text usually unless i don't
want to
so or let's have to think about it
and that's scared that's crazy
so for me that evidence seems more
realistic
you know and i worry about the long-term
effects of us not having an imagination
anymore
and things like that
but i think if i start if now do i
believe that one day we won't turn you
know get into a.i
where we just lay on a floor with our
mouths open
and somebody you know we go clock in at
work and we're just laying there all day
watching our avatar work
and that becomes another world yeah i
could see that happening
i could see a huge transition of wealth
in that way too because
then you only can earn money in the
avatar world
you know in this brainscape
so suddenly all the money whatever you
have on the outside doesn't matter
anymore
you know i think it is interesting
everything you know i don't know if it
always happens but it'd be interesting
if a great equalizer
comes across
and it sets it all at zero again
and then you find out what's in you
oh am i doing am i just gonna cry am i
just gonna
am i just gonna think am i just gonna
judge am i just gonna blame
or am i is some little part of me that
still has a pilot light of damn
manhood and bravado and womanhood
gonna [ __ ] flicker
and pick up a [ __ ] hard stick
and say let's go i don't know
you know i don't know i
do not know
i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
home
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been
brown